it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you get some peanuts and
cracker jacks because MLB the show steps
up to the plate be rekindled with your
old friend Matt vaskar sein with fancy
dynamic Sun lighting so the shadows
change with the seasons and it looks so
nice on those lush new grass patterns
stadiums get new Jumbotrons and
buildings in the background get lights
but still no retractable roofs maybe
next year you can catch this bad boy on
March 31st but only if you're on
PlayStation so what about those xbox
owners who like baseball well RBI
Baseball 15 the follow-up to last year's
RBI Baseball 14 is here to simplify your
complicated baseball controls with the
touch of just two buttons authentic
stadiums and full 40-man rosters for all
30 teams online multiplayer and stat
tracking have been added this year
chicago cubs first baseman anthony rizzo
is on the cover take that yasiel puig
adventurers prepare to explore the
Forgotten Realms to combat vilandra and
protect the city of Neverwinter the fold
free to play game will be launching on
31st for members of xbox live gold the
game will add certain console features
such as friends list integration and
will have optimized controls help you
ease into planning on a console
neverwinter will separate the servers
for PC and console Xbox one owners will
also get access to some content like
free premium races so you can look out
for neverwinter on the 31st also this
week you join the hundred demo corpse
and fight more badass Oni in Tokyo Denki
hua me
that's one frightening kitty the
animation is beautiful but the content
is no joke talking attack on Titan style
death sequences where hordes and hordes
of nameless fighters are slaughtered so
probably not for the kids unless you're
a cool parent the fight begins on the
31st please open your books to page 31
and let's start with the first paragraph
on paper bound this four-person local
multiplayer game allows you to
manipulate gravity as you run around
trying to cut your paper buddies heads
off play in paper scenes straight from
all those books you totally read and
didn't buy the cliff notes for use
scissors for pure pandemonium as you
slice your friends and sheer fun
paperbound comes out on the 31st finally
turn up the bass on your speakers
because axiom verge the retro-styled 2d
Metroidvania action adventure is finally
releasing on ps4 this week hot slick
action bound to perfectly placed pixels
in a crazy detailed world that requires
nothing but pure skill and your undying
affection this game is something to
write your mama about you can grab that
on the 31st for further details visit
gamespot com release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week